Troisième jour en Corée du Sud !
[안녕하세요] (Bonjour en coréen)
Je suis actuellement au restaurant, assis en tailleur
Ambiance tamisée posée
Aujourd'hui au programme,
Nous allons aller dans un stand de tir
J'ai jamais tiré... De ma vie, j'ai envie de voir ce que ça fait,
Parce que dans les jeux vidéos on tire tout le temps,
On passe des milliers d'heures à tirer avec des armes virtuelles
J'aime pas spécialement les armes à feu,
J'suis juste curieux de découvrir la sensation de tirer !
Voilà si ça se trouve j'vais détester, ça va me faire flipper,
et j'aurais plus jamais envie de tirer, j'en.. j'en sais rien..
J'espère que la première vidéo vous a plu
Moi elle m'a plu
J'ai un pouce bleu, j'me suis abonné
Je vous dis à tout à l'heure dans un..
..Stand de tir !
고맙습니다
Ça veut pas dire "bon appétit", ça veut dire "merci" mais..
J'sais pas comment on dit bon appétit (맛있게 드세요 :)
Le stand de tir est juste au dessus d'une banque..
La banque est là
Si vous voulez braquer une banque c'est easy
Les amis on y est je dois choisir avec quel pistolet tirer !
On a le choix entre six trucs,
Dont le Glock et l'USP.
En tant que joueur de Counter Strike,
J'avoue que..!
Ok les amis j'ai dû passer sur mon téléphone parce que..
J'ai pas le droit d'amener ma caméra là dedans
C'est juste là le stand de tir !
Mais je crois que je vais pouvoir glisser mon téléphone dans un truc
Pour me filmer.
Ça c'est la bonne nouvelle !
Ça fait des gros.. Des gros bruits j'aime pas du tout..!
Waaah.. C'est impressionnant à voir.
J'ai très peur !
Ok ça va être à mon tour
Ok les amis j'viens de sortir de cet endroit
Euh.. Oké
Ah dès qu'ils ouvrent la porte du truc ça fait un bruit de malade !
Bah écoutez eeeuuuuuuh...
Je me suis CHIÉ DESSUS.
C'était vraiment flippant, ça m'a vraiment mis mal..
De manière générale, j'supporte pas trop les GROS bruits
Et là quand tu tires une balle ça fait un bruit mais de malade mental !
Donc ça me terrifie !
Mais j'ai tiré dix balles et j'ai fait un score de 91 pts
Donc en moyenne, j'tire pas au milieu, je tire dans lee.. Cercle juste après
Ouais j'ai le même skill au tir qu'aux fléchettes,
Ouais tout ce qui est cibles j'connais bien ouais !
En fait y'a un putain de recul
Quand tu tires, et encore j'avais un Glock donc c'est pas un recul de malade par rapport à..
..à un Colt ou j'sais pas trop quoi
Tu t'prends même une p'tite vague de chaleur tranquillement sur le visage
C'est assez ouf !
Je re ferais pas euh..
Caca culotte '-'
Ça par contre !
Ça je ref'rai plein de fois !
Un grand merci à Nadoyo, l'agence qui m'a permis de tirer dix balles aujourd'hui
Et qui est responsable de mon traumatisme !
On va rejoindre un ami
Qui s'appelle Fabien, c'est le pote qui vit ici, depuis des années maintenant
Et il va nous faire visiter une université !
Bon j'suis avec mon gars sûr Fabien ! Ça va Fabien ?
Fabien : Yo !
Fabien c'est l'un des rares hommes qui étudie à l'université dans laquelle on va se rendre aujourd'hui
Qu'on va vous montrer,
Parce que c'est l'université la plus grande du monde, c'est ça ?
Fabien : L'université de femmes !
Lucas : De FEMMES !
Donc celles qu'on préfère, finalement !
Fabien : Oui donc je suis dans une université de femmes.
Lucas : Voilà, est-ce que c'est un bon plan ou pas ?
Fabien : C'est un plan plutôt..
Lucas : Un plan plutôt pas mal !
Fabien : mais plutôt.. Oppressant !
Lucas : Et en fait c'est totalement immense, il a pu l'intégrer parce que t'es un étranger ici
T'es pas de nationalité coréenne
Fabien : Exactement
Ça veut dire que les meufs quand elles voient un mec dans l'université c'est forcément un étranger ?
Fabien : Ouais c'est forcément un étranger SOIT c'est un coréen pervers qui est venu ici pour..
Lucas : Prendre un MAX de photos !
Fabien : Ce qui arrive quand même assez régulièrement !
Lucas : AH OUAIS ?
Oh putain c'est badant mec !
Attends mais c'est une université mais aussi un centre commercial quoi là y'a carrément une boulangerie
Fabien : Y'a une Fnac et y'a genre..
Lucas : Y'A UNE FNAC DANS L'UNIVERSITÉ MEC !
Et p'tain cette structure a été faite pour que quand tu fais un vlog ça résonne un max et les gens te regardent mal !
Fabien : La cuisine coréenne de Fabien Yoon !
Lucas : Voilà. C'était l'instant promo merci à tous
Nous pénétrons dans l'enceinte du bâtiment (tant qu'c'est pas ailleurs..)
T'as des restaurants, tranquillement
Fabien : Il y a énormément d'étudiants en ce moment puisque nous sommes dans une période d'examens
Lucas : CHHT !
Attention l'anecdote exceptionnelle dans 3, 2, 1 :
Tu gagnes des points quand tu vas à l'église
Si on fait ça en France, ça part en guerre civile
Y'a carrément une salle de sport dans l'université
Tu t'es mis bien Fabien à la salle de sport ?
Fabien : J'étais comme dans.. le clip de.. c'était quoi ?
Call on meeeeeee ♪
Lucas : Attention extrait c'est incroyable cette vidéo est géniale !
Par contre ça t'a pas empêché d'avoir un corps de lâche !
C'était les vacances, on est le 31 décembre
..et y'a des gens qui sont en train d'étudier derrière moi
Putain l'espace est immense quoi c'est complètement dingue..
Après j'ai vu elle est pas très fort en maths
Voilà c'était une blague de niveau un
Y'a aussi une partie crèche, ici
Voilà
Ou alors ils sont très forts et ils ont beaucoup d'années d'avance, je sais pas (ça se peut hein)
Ok les amis on s'est réfugiés dans un bowling qui est en fait une boîte de nuit !
Et vu qu'y'a du monde à toutes les pistes ils nous font attendre dans une salle où tu peux faire..
Du ping-pong !
Fabien : Oh ! OH ! OOH !
Lucas : Eeet bim !
Fabien : Ah bataaaard
Lucas : La technique du fdp que t'as envie d'insulter !
Lucas : Ooh !
Fabien : Ah l'batard.
Ok après ce match de titans on est enfin sur la piste de bowling ! C'est partiiii !
Tout va se jouer- - AAAAAAH
Tout va se jouer au dernier lancer attention c'est terrible!
Fabien : Oh !
Fabien : OH !
Après cette triste défaite, Fabien a voulu me consoler
En allant dans un café pour chat
Fabien : En passant du monde de brutes..
Lucas : À un monde d'amour
Et de paix
Et de félins
Et c'qui est ouf c'est que dans ce café là les chats ils sont à l'adoption
C'est à dire que si t'as un coup de cœur pour un chat, tu peux repartir avec, l'adopter vraiment !
Fabien : T'as de la place dans ta valise ou pas ?
Lucas : Nan ! Mais j'en ai déjà deux à la maison
Fabien : Ah ouais..
Lucas : Ça fait bizarre de revoir des chats parce que Lua et Jumbo ils me manquent terriblement finalement quand je suis pas chez moi..
Regardez y'en a partout !
J'regarde où je marche
Il mange
Et dans ce café là y'a même une petite mezzanine pour aller dormir avec des chats là-haut
Y'a même un étage..
C'est leur petit repère !
Y'a plein de petits compartiments comme ça, pour se poser, et les chats viennent avec toi
Après une bonne défaite au bowling, rien ne pouvait mieux me consoler !
Il est tranquille
Attends son cube il fait vraiment sa
sa taille quoi ! Y'a pas un centimètre qui dépasse !
Fabien : Mais les chats ils aiment ça quoi ! Ils aiment trop les trucs trop petits. Ils aiment être à l’étroit
Salut le boule !
Comment ça va mon grand ?
Eh il est fâché, il aime pas du tout c'que je fais !
On va le laisser en paix !  Il a dû perdre au bowling lui aussi putain
La bouffe
Eh y'en a un il s'est caché mon gars !
Trouvez le chat dans cet espace
"Je suis caché !"
"Je n'aime pas les gens !"
J'suis actuellement en train de faire le nouvel an à 홍대/hongdae [quartier coréen], mon quartier préféré
C'est la folie !
On est six milliards et y'a le feu d'artifices !
Les amis, il est six heure du matin ici en Corée et je suis en mode IGLOO, car il fait très TRÈS TRÈÈÈS FROID
Des températures négatives..
Et en fait c'est la guerre aux taxis,
C'est à dire que y'a un milliard de personnes qui cherchent un taxi et y'a que 20 taxis
Et ça fait déjà une heure qu'on marche !
Fabien : Mais on a Miaouss
Lucas : Mais on a Miaouss !
Fabien : Et ça c'est beau !
Lucas : On a craqué pour une petite salle d'arcade
Et on s'est régalés !
Ok, métro. On est déçus
Décéder.
Il est 8h du matin et je dois dans 2 heures me lever,
Pour aller prendre le train direction Busan !
C'est la 2e plus grande ville de Corée, ça va être vraiment génial, y'a euh..
La MER !
Là bas y'a un immense marché où ils vendent un max de produits de la mer
Le 'blème c'est que j'aime pas du tout les produits de la mer mais c'est pas grave ! J'aime le poisson
Aimez-vous les fruits de mer ?
Ou êtes-vous plutôt viande ?
Eeuh..
Abonnez vous
Voilà
Au revoir
Ooh la caméra s'adapte, merde !